en reviso de prensa analizaremos
precisamente la acusación contra el
expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump por los documentos clasificados
que encontraron en su casa y para eso
nos acompaña Marta Moya Marta Buenos
días y cuéntenos que dicen los
principales medios estadounidenses Hola
María Clara Buenos días hemos destacado
para empezar cuatro portadas que hablan
por supuesto de la imputación contra el
expresidente Donald Trump vamos a
empezar con el New York Times que este
viernes titula Trump es acusado por el
caso de los documentos clasificados
sostiene Además este periódico y citando
a Fuentes familiarizadas con el tema
porque los casos los cargos todavía no
se conocen hasta el martes que la
acusación incluiría delitos de mala
gestión de documentación clasificada
también obstrucción a la justicia Por
otra parte hemos destacado el Washington
post Que prácticamente titula por el
mismo lado que el New York Times
diciendo Trump imputado por los
documentos clasificados en esos siete
presuntos cargos contra el ex mandatario
estarían retención deliberada de
documentos secretos obstrucción a la
justicia y conspiración el expresidente
se muestra desafiante dijo ayer que era
una víctima de la administración biden y
además se declaró inocente varios de sus
rivales republicanos sostiene esta
portada del Washington post le han
expresado su ayuda incluso candidatos
que se van a presentar a la nominación
republicana y también dice el Washington
bosque esto genera un terremoto en las
filas republicanas porque al final Trump
es el candidato mejor postulado para
ganar la nominación y esto Pues también
implica que es el primer ex presidente
señalado directamente por el
Departamento de Justicia Por otra parte
el Boston globe titula este viernes
Trump acusado de nuevo esta vez por los
documentos la investigación del abogado
especial sobre los documentos hallados
en su residencia en mara lago ha dado
lugar a cargos federales sin precedentes
por eso dice el Boston globe Y por
último hemos destacado el New York post
que dispara ambos lados titula salve a
los bandidos a Trump por el caso de los
documentos clasificados ya baiden por
ese presunto soborno de un empresario
ucraniano cuando él era vicepresidente
de Obama y cuáles podrían ser las
implicaciones para Trump y empecemos con
lo que dice el New York Times pues María
Clara primero el New York Times titula
que la acusación de ayer del fiscal Jack
Smith completa el círculo de la historia
de Donald Trump empieza así este
análisis del York Times que dice hace
algún tiempo no mucho de hecho Trump
dijo que le preocupaba esto la seguridad
nacional cuando su oponente estaba en la
mira su oponente Entonces era hillary
Clinton y cuando entonces Joan podía
utilizarlo como un arma política la
acusaba entonces a Clinton de utilizar
un servidor de correo electrónico
personal y no Uno seguro gubernamental
sigue este análisis diciendo siete años
después Trump enfrenta cargos federales
por poner en riesgo la seguridad
nacional por llevarse documentos
clasificados después de dejar la Casa
Blanca Esta es la segunda acusación
contra el expresidente sin embargo dice
este análisis del neward Times que en
muchos aspectos Esta última acusación
opaca a la primera dada pues la gravedad
legal y el peligro político y qué dice
de Washington post pues me declaro el
Washington post nos hace una serie de
preguntas y respuestas alrededor de esta
segunda acusación dice por ejemplo que
un gran Jurado de 23 personas
refundó no O dijo que sí a que Trump
fuera acusado después de que el fiscal
lo hiciera que los cargos no sean
conocidos que se van a presentar el
martes que Ochoa no va a ser arrestado
probablemente porque se va a presentar
voluntariamente en el Distrito Federal
de Miami que le tomaran las huellas
dactilares y será que el juez le pedirá
si se declara culpable o no y que
después presentará las condiciones de
liberación Es muy improbable que el
expresidente vaya a la cárcel y que pese
a todo Incluso si es condenado se podrá
presentar a las elecciones en 2024 y muy
rápidamente que dicen de USA today y Los
Ángeles Times Pues el expresidente ya
quería armar un espectáculo cuando
compareció en el Distrito Federal de
Manhattan en abril y que cabe esperar
que ahora lo propio en su tierra natal
en Florida cuando comparezca ante la
justicia el próximo martes puede
esperarse desde una bueno lectura de
cargos tranquila hasta incluso episodios
de violencia lo que dice el usai today
es que sería un error que Trump cargara
contra la justicia durante la
presentación de cargos porque le podrían
encarcelar por desacato a la justicia y
él Los Ángeles Times citamos una opinión
de Harry litman que dice que la
acusación contra Trump es tan
impresionante como Inevitable sin
embargo dice textualmente que el
departamento de Justicia ha demostrado
valentía y dedicación al imputar al
expresidente Marta habíamos hablado al
inicio de las noticias que Instagram
tiene un algoritmo que puede promover la
pedofilia sí María Clara esto es un
análisis y una investigación del Wall
Street journal junto a investigadores de
las universidades de Stanford y de
Massachusetts qué dicen en esta
investigación conjunta que el algoritmo
de Instagram impulsa las cuentas de
usuarios que compran y venden contenidos
sexual de menores de edad meta propiedad
de Mark Zuckerberg dice este análisis
que no se limita alojar Estas
actividades sino que conecta a pedófilos
con sus sistemas de recomendaciones las
cuentas utilizan hashtags como pederasta
o sexo preadolescente y tienen millones
de publicaciones Aunque la política
interna de meta prohíbe estas conductas
Instagram a través de su algoritmo las
permite en estas cuentas se vean niños
Por ejemplo haciéndose daño a sí mismos
realizando actos sexuales con animales
incluso
ofrecen servicios de menores para
encuentros personales con potenciales
pedófilos dice también esta bueno esta
investigación del Western journal que
meta ha dicho que está investigando lo
sucedido Gracias Marta por la revista de
prensa gracias Me declaro